I've always been an admirer of the Kennedy family and JFK in particular.
I've always had a connection to him.
And so throughout my life, I've read a lot, a lot.
If there's a book about him or his presidency, I've probably read it.
So when this came my way, I was honored to be asked and it's been an amazing experience.
I think for known figures the key is inhabitation, not imitation.
"I am today announcing my candidacy for the presidency of the United States."
My goal was to play a husband, a father, a brother, a man with a big job.
Responsibility is mine.
I am the president.
That was the stuff that I was looking to capture about him.
All of that stuff, I think, you find in your research and you bring to the set...
...and you try to infuse it whenever you can, and that's what makes it authentic.
The goal is just to make him an honest, real man.
He did things nobody ever dreamed possible...
...and his ability to inspire people, we've never seen since.